what's up with the GLA double dollar
sign Nissan that's right glasses Malone
and you already know man check a real
one out the bootleg Kev podcast I'm over
here listening to Kev talk [ __ ] feel me
[ __ ] and he don't want to admit some
of that little nausea [ __ ] is corny it's
corny but check me out man bootleg cash
y'all
yo man bullet care podcast special guest
in here this guy is supposed to have
been on the show a bunch of times
my guy Jim alone glasses Malone is here
what's up with a care welcome man and
thank you for having me I'm just looking
at all these plaques and [ __ ] plaques
flax Galore
yo um you launched your podcast finally
yeah which I think had been something
that was long overdue
because every time you do an interview
every time you you have very very
polarizing opinions I'm not saying
they're wrong or right their opinions so
you know but I think um I'm glad did
Charlemagne have a lot to do with it's
all Charlemagne convincing you to do it
did it yeah I would have never did it
I never would have did it what what was
like the deciding Factory like you know
what [ __ ] I'm gonna do this podcast
just trusting somebody that's a friend
yeah see you see is the homie you know
what I mean and and he's giving me he's
giving me pretty good advice up to this
point if I asked him he's always been
honest and sincere so when he came to me
I was like I just can't keep telling him
no like I'll try it let's go how's it
going
it's just getting good to me now we're
about 24 conversations in so right it's
starting to make sense
um
I think I did my favorite one the other
day was about covet and I talked to this
doctor that's dealt with like
somewhere near I think his number was
over 2 000 patients of covet yeah okay
like just so many and he was saying to
us
just different ideas so it was really it
was it was very much a polarizing
conversation it was about like we talked
about the vaccine and the confusions in
the black community and he understood
and he started explaining what the
vaccine were you know was about
different ideas and
um it was good so I thought it was dope
are you vaccinated no do you plan on
getting vaccinated uh yes so that's
something that you're open to and and
because you brought up the black
community in the vaccine because it
feels like they're the the two biggest
um
points of the population that aren't
getting vaccinated or like the really
hardcore right-wing people and a lot of
the African-American Community when you
look at the numbers yeah what do you
think is like
the disconnect or the misinformation or
the and I'm not saying that the vaccine
is like sure a shoe in like I think
people should do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to know you know what I'm saying I
I don't like the idea of forcing anyone
to do anything I think you should get it
it's a good idea but I I definitely am
against any sort of like mandate because
at the end of the day we're still in
America there's some [ __ ] supposed to be
a free country you know what I'm saying
but what are your thoughts on the whole
just the whole [ __ ] man like with coven
and and and the vaccine and all that
um right-wing America and Black America
just are the two biggest
groups that don't trust the government I
don't know why right-wing America
doesn't you know because everything's
been good the government does so much
good for them ideally I would like to
believe so I understand our concern you
know
it ain't necessarily like it's been made
that you want to help us live right so
it's always that confusion and um they
just did a a bad job with handling it
and I can't knock them because I'm not
saying I would have did a better one it
did just kind of happen fast nobody was
playing in this [ __ ] yeah so you you
making a thousand adjustments on the
swing and it was just so much
misinformation the whole time it was
just like bad decisions like you closing
out everybody's businesses but then you
open Walmart which don't make sense in
theory you should have closed down
Walmart and opened all the small
businesses and allow minimum people so
as always these questions and that
bothered people I'm saying don't nobody
black think America want them to live
fair and then everybody is like well you
know it's the same people taking them
but [ __ ] they can manipulate [ __ ] for
DNA we still got special things about
our anatomy that make us special so it's
always those questions
do you um were you ever like you say
you're you plan on getting vaccinated
was there something were you ever like
on the side of being like nah [ __ ] that
I ain't doing it did something happen to
convince you to do it or you just
haven't gotten around to getting it yet
well it's not first off right so
obviously I don't necessarily have a ton
of respect for the FDA they do a
horrible job you know with the foods and
plus it's not a it's not even FDA
approved right now that's what I'm
saying so I'm saying I don't have a ton
of trust for the FDA right right but I
do respect that they're attempting to
act like they're trying so at least fool
me a little bit like you act like you
care but if if the FDA hasn't approved
it I'm just like hold up you know it
ain't that much of an emergency I'm not
that scared of Don enough to where I'm
like I'ma just rush out and just do
anything plus I didn't do a ton of
research on the vaccines you know I'm
saying I didn't know like it's new
methods that they create the new
vaccines with now you mean like the
Pfizer those are new methods that are
just now being enacted where your body
is creating you know from what the
doctor explained to me on the podcast
right your body you know they're giving
you like the protein makers and your
body is creating the the uh Kobe you
know the covet virus itself and you know
you're fighting it with your own stuff
I don't even like the sound of that
right that's like you know refining my
wheat or refining my sugar or
pasteurizing my damn milk stop [ __ ]
with my [ __ ] give me you know make it a
little weaker you know so if I do it on
you know when I do it I would do the
Johnson Johnson that's me obviously the
Johnson Johnson that [ __ ] up a lot of
people but me you know that's what I
would [ __ ] with just take the one the
one one and done well it's the old
school way it's the old school type
vaccine
yeah yeah when they take the virus
weaken it up a little bit so your body
could happen
that's how it used to be so I like that
way versus you know again you know all
of this
modern stuff of you know convenience
speed I'm not tripping I got time like
I'd rather fight it and deal with it
like that way yeah I think that like for
me like this whole covet [ __ ] is like
I mean obviously I'm tired of this [ __ ]
it's it's to the point where it's like
damn there's a new variant and I feel
like especially here
you know we ain't [ __ ]
liberal it's so you know we're we're we
are in the most liberal well I mean
Portland you could do heroin and it's
it's all right but you know but we're in
California yeah it's pretty good it's
pretty close to Liberal it's just
liberal of the world yeah
um and and it's funny you said that as
soon as you said that it made me think
of something so like I was so invested
in the conversation of conservative and
liberals so I didn't realize how States
view each other as States and I remember
I'm jumping on uh the guy yellow wolf
I'm jumping on his head cause he's
talking [ __ ] about California I'm not
realizing he talking about that whole
literal conservative ship and I remember
telling like hey cause you better watch
what you see
out like now I'm like oh I get it this
is some white people white people [ __ ]
yeah I don't know I mean I I didn't know
yellow was talking about California yeah
he had like this crazy this was like
about two years ago he was like talking
[ __ ] like you know [ __ ] Yuppie
[ __ ] and [ __ ] Liberties
talking [ __ ] like hey bro you got to
take California out your mouth like that
yeah yeah but I didn't realize I was
ignorant to the conversation I just mean
in terms of like how play like
everyone's handled he's right well I'm
talking about right now how how we see
everything getting handled right so I
could see California shut down again
yeah yeah I could see it happening
because we got to put on the show yeah
cause we gotta act like we care about
the citizens right right now I don't
know if that's gonna happen with uh
Gavin trying to keep his gig you know
what I'm saying he's looking real bad
for the Slick looking real bad
but no in terms of just like covet like
I think I've kind of been on all
spectrums of like I'm over this [ __ ]
okay I have had it I got vaccined what
the [ __ ] else do you need me to do
you just don't work that way man gotta
you know the thing about California you
know even down to the culture itself is
all about saving face so California
always trying to save face from the top
of the food chain such a huge economy on
its own that everyone looks at Cali you
know obviously places like New York as
like this the example yeah for the rest
of the country yeah then you got
[ __ ] like Texas who are like
suck my dick up through our thing
Florida Florida
I love I love that attitude that's the
gangster rap attitude Texas and Florida
is the full gangster rap battle hey you
talked about
um conservative liberal [ __ ]
I feel like people could go onto your
Twitter at any given time during the
election and during the last few years
and maybe confuse you or label you as a
black conservative yeah because I've
seen you retweet [ __ ] from Candace Owens
and yeah so where do you because you're
you're like I I love you because you're
unapologetically yourself and I'm honest
and and what you think you will say it
no matter whose feelings again the
funniest [ __ ] I ever saw you say was
about Rick Ross's clothes and yo Ross is
a boss but a killer those clothes ain't
made in his size in my top five you feel
me as my favorite I think he's still mad
at me for but I'm like it's not about
him as much as it's about how the public
wants to view
you know what the conversation is you
know how much they want to exaggerated
so you know you
where they don't make that shirt in 5x
right they don't make none of that [ __ ]
but again but no but like you're so
honest with your opinion and
um I think it's why people love you I
think it's why people follow you I think
and I just hate you too there's a reason
why they hate you but I'm curious like
there's definitely some of your
viewpoints would you consider yourself a
black conservative and I'm probably the
most liberal person in America that's to
be an honest
but what I'm not is full of [ __ ] fair
enough and that's the problem with the
liberal population it's more for front
it's more for face value it's more to
make you feel good inside yeah they want
to look like they want people to look at
look at me I'm a good person versus I
genuinely am a good person I give a [ __ ]
I genuinely care about those points so I
could never stand on the side with them
and the thing I respect about
conservative is they genuinely the piece
of [ __ ] that they are right see I could
[ __ ] with anything genuine I can't [ __ ]
with things when people faking like it's
some kind of confusion that like you
know uh the concept of racism is just
rooted and conservative liberals it's
the same [ __ ] way they just acting
like they [ __ ] with you yeah I think
that um the most fresh because I would
say that I'm like historically very
liberal I've devoted Democrat every time
you know what I'm saying but I think
that
what's crazy about what Trump did was he
brought out the radicals on every side
exactly because I've never seen the
Liberals get so gangster man them those
have some [ __ ] it was a brother out
there man this [ __ ] was talking
crap to my Hebrew I'm ready I beat
somebody ass I'm like the [ __ ] is going
on yeah Trump brought out the crazy
racist like scum of the earth that was
always there but now they're more
comfortable saying it and and you know
which I was good with and then on the
other end it's like
cancer culture is so
prevalent now and it's like there's this
loud minority on Twitter of people that
control corporations that control
celebrities because it's like it might
be a hundred [ __ ] on Twitter
but if you get a hundred tweets and
you're a celebrity because you said
something that might not sit well with
whatever the [ __ ] is the
the woke [ __ ] talking point for the
week
you gotta go and apologize well you know
what I'm saying like I just think it
sucks because now literally there's no
like I feel like reason and like just
being a normal person is not crazy
it's like it's hard nowadays because
there's each extreme on each side
controls
whether it's the media whether it was on
TV whether it's you know it's not what
you're being controlled by
people and also giving a [ __ ] what
people think well you're controlled by
money right so like like let's say the
baby in his situation right
he's only losing because he allowed them
to control how much money he's making he
allowed them to say You're Gonna book me
on these festivals until we decide that
this is our culture and we are
controlling it and we could do our own
thing we Empower them lame ass festivals
facts we Empower those Yuppie ass events
we we're the reason that you exist
it's some kind of confusion that we need
you it's some kind of confusion that
rolling loud we didn't make that [ __ ] we
made that [ __ ] you take us off of that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is nothing but a [ __ ]
reject version of [ __ ] Woodstock
right so again until we understand the
power in our culture that this hip-hop
[ __ ] is well guess what every time we
try to go to mainstream America anytime
they feel like they want to they could
just slap us down and be like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] Get Down Bam but if we decided to
take it into our own hands and control
it then we could say what we want to we
could control our own message right now
we we have the control of the dollar I
think the baby is probably the first
example I think I've I really feel like
where there's like
[ __ ] if he's not canceled this
is the closest I've seen someone
as far as hip-hop is concerned of like a
superstar right now I'm not talking
about rappers that have said dumb [ __ ]
and then we don't hear from him I mean a
superstar right and and honestly I think
what the baby said
at best is ignorant at best is ignorant
but really at the least it's just
exclusionary like I wouldn't be mad if I
went to a concert with Elton John he
jamming his songs bro and he's like hey
if you suck dicks Make Some Noise as a
man I wouldn't be mad I just wouldn't
make noise right feel me I wouldn't be
like oh you know Elton John excluded me
in these conversation Bros stop trying
to always be included that's what's
wrong with America now they always want
to act like everybody needs to be
included that's not true you just don't
need to be discriminated against or
necessarily you know uh uh somebody
being you know bigoted you know
prejudiced right but I don't got to [ __ ]
with you we so desperate to make
everybody [ __ ] with each other man [ __ ]
that it's like everybody wants to be
included in everything which isn't
necessarily don't got nothing to do with
you bro My Views as much as My Views are
liberal I would never be with them
[ __ ] this [ __ ] like I I got way too
much attitude my [ __ ] stand up and
conservatives at least they're just
[ __ ] feel me and I couldn't be that
because I don't have those views but I
respect that it's authentic and it's
from this is who we are versus somebody
y'all the same way but y'all trying to
act like y'all give a [ __ ] about people
yeah I think with the baby like
I really didn't think like first of all
we've been in plenty of rap shows plenty
of nightclubs where they say yo if your
[ __ ] don't stink if you ain't got no
ass [ __ ] get mad he's excluding us my
[ __ ] stinks it's not my face I have a I
have a I have a [ __ ] yeast infection
it makes my vagina smell he just screwed
me like I don't know what I'm saying is
like what he what he did was rooted in
like a real thing in the clubs
especially in the South sure it's normal
now
did did in my opinion did he [ __ ] up
sure I think the worst thing he said was
the HIV thing yeah but because it was
insensitive but at the same time right
all he I mean and I'm not saying that he
needed to do this but all he really had
to do was be like hey man you know if
you've ever been to the club in the
South this is just how we I just said
some crazy [ __ ] off the top of my head
obviously if you have HIV that was you
know he doubled he like quadruple down
on that but she's but you supposed to
right and and again right it's not
saying everybody he's not he didn't say
everybody with HIV or Aids dies in two
to three weeks that's not what he said I
know he said if you didn't if you don't
have AIDS or some [ __ ] that you're gonna
die in two to three weeks make some
noise Make some noise again it's one of
those things where we are hearing
somebody and not listening to them and
we're reacting listen if you really
cared about the baby what you would have
did you say hey man you need to sit down
with Magic Johnson y'all need to have a
conversation on tape this is required
for me he will educate you and you lace
magic with the tips and they have a
conversation that's recorded you put it
on TV educate people let this man go get
his [ __ ] money but again it's not
about that it's about [ __ ] you better
watch what you say it ain't about none
of that other [ __ ] it's a thousand
[ __ ] I said worse but [ __ ]
watch what you say you're getting out of
line [ __ ] you you feel me we you
getting out of control well I think what
you said too is like a lot of this [ __ ]
is about saving face or or or acting
like you care right so if you're
if as soon as one Festival took them off
you knew any other festival that kept
them on would look like a promotion
point oh no they're homophobic yeah or
or like you said all the festivals that
took them off you saw it on the shade
room you saw their flyer on every single
news Outlet so it was like not only is
it free promotion but it also checks the
box of like okay we kind of have to do
this because one [ __ ] took them
off if they'd if every other festival
doesn't follow suit they're gonna get
looked at like they're they're
homophobic and I think I just think that
like like you said like I liked what
Miley Cyrus posted because she was like
I would like to educate him as opposed
to and then she's not [ __ ] I hate him El
John come on I'm like bro you don't even
use your Twitter bro Madonna what the
[ __ ] you bro you ain't did nothing that
matters do you think that it was smart
for him to though like lean into it yeah
because you're a [ __ ] gangster rap
you're a [ __ ] gangster that's fair
feel me but the only the only thing was
as long as he's okay with losing the
revenue that they was providing for him
he'll be fine but obviously he wasn't he
came out and apologized and that I mean
he's probably getting three four hundred
a show yeah but you got to make your own
three four hundreds I don't disagree
with you but I'm just saying I mean you
know after the seventh or eighth one you
start adding up that money
I went through the same because the baby
but whether we like it or not he's a
gangster rapper he's also a pop star but
that's the but that's the point because
he is a gangster rapper that's fair so
the first time you turn into a pop star
stop being a gangster rapper it's
probably not gonna work out
I went through the same kind of thing it
wasn't
quite that because my stuff was still
rooted in a bit of intellect where I was
talking about Lil Nas X right and I was
saying somebody asked me on my Twitter
they said hey man G um
you know do I think Lil Nas X is a is
like a tool for of LGBT I said well
really I tweeted but I didn't at the
person I said little nazex is not a
puppet for lgbtq if anything he's a
puppet for white supremacy and I said
really more than anything that I'm not
feeling about his art you know I'm
saying he's [ __ ] corny
like it's just corny as [ __ ] is it
executed well yes is there some decent
idea there yes the overall idea of the
whole [ __ ] is just actually lame and
corny he's it's a guy named Bert
Williams right that was a
that was a uh
a black dude that used to do blackface
he was a super talented actor but he was
doing corny [ __ ] but bro why would you
blackface your [ __ ] and that's what I
feel like he's doing with that culture
it's like you just over the top bro and
I get it but it's like sometimes it's
corny that's what I say about little
nausea because you and I had a little uh
conversation about a little nazex in the
Satan's shoe and all that [ __ ] but but
when I saw your Tweet about about the uh
uh white supremacy thing and I was like
I truly believe now obviously he's a pop
musician me and you and the type of
music that we I'm not riding around in
my car listening a little now nobody's
listening people are like yeah like
white people right or like Main Street
people he's a pop star sure right he
makes pop music but he's a brother and
that's the problem that's fair that's
fair when you're a brother we expect
your [ __ ] to have some soul some depth
he's [ __ ] a cornball and that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] irritating and your your records
got to be as good as old if you're gonna
do it so listen you can have that
position that you subjectively don't
like his music right
I don't know if I don't I like Old Town
Road I just don't like the shitty the
last few records so as someone who is on
the radio side right someone who can
like say oh like that's a hit record
that's like I feel like the the record
he put out with the uh what's it called
monetaro
I heard that record and I was like oh
this is a hit
now this that record did go number one
at radio right it went number one yeah
but it probably was more rooted in ads
than just it worked his way up it was
probably number one within the first
week or two no it wasn't it was a slow
build I promise you I could show you the
media based charts it barely hit also it
came out before the video no no no no
the video came out and it barely hit
number one on Rhythm like maybe like
three or four weeks ago what was that a
month ago no the song came out in April
beautiful it actually came out in March
third week of March because that's when
the video came out yeah I went through
some legal [ __ ] this you remember right
okay go ahead go ahead so I I heard that
record and I was like okay this is a
this is a good record for for radio like
it's a pop it's it's gonna kill it on
KISS FM it's going you know but is it
for me nah but you know the [ __ ] I'm
listening to oh sure but I could
subjectively look in little nausea's
music and be like in my opinion now you
got your opinion I'm not saying it ain't
corny why but I think he's making good
records
I'm not saying he's making good rap
records or good Soul records I just
think he's making good record but you
know my limitation it'll be disrespected
and saw me and think that I'm just some
kind of I like records right no no
you're right and you're someone who's
always been that way so Montero as a
record is even as a pop record is this
it's written decent
it's executed I just think it's very
like
it lacks something original right and
don't get me wrong because a lot of
times right we're in spaces where you
know people are doing the next thing or
the thing that everybody's doing but pop
is definitely a higher standard where
you supposed to dig deeper like Bruno
Mars makes pop records that's fair and
that [ __ ] is some [ __ ] fire of course so
when you say a record I'm thinking like
I mean would I rather listen to Little
Naz X's Montero or silk Sonic leave the
door open silk Sonic leave the door
opening 50 years that got sold I would
rather listen to NSYNC I and that's fair
because the record is better I'm not
saying that the records aren't better
I'm just saying he's got good records it
ain't like he's putting out dust no
they're not horrible they're not
horrible and so my thing is is I think
little Naz X
is somebody who
like you said when you first got in here
we had an off-camera conversation yeah
about a conversation you have with
T-Pain no and how you were like yo
whatever you are lean into it a thousand
percent so you started wearing your
glasses because your name's glasses moon
but you never used to wear glasses no so
now you wear glasses but they're big
little Naz X is a gay dude right yeah
and he's leaning into that but but again
right so I agree right it's a way to do
everything but then so like let's say if
my name is glasses right and I'm a [ __ ]
rapper those are my two Brands and I
walk in this [ __ ] where bandanas
tied around my wrist Bandana's title
around all my joints my neck my heads
it's corny it's it's extra so not in
this way past this is extra that [ __ ] is
stupid and ridiculous but that'll mean
everybody can't tell right so let me ask
you this though because if little Nas X
was a dude who was straight and he was
making out with [ __ ] on stage and
there was a bunch of half naked [ __ ]
dancing around him nobody would question
him that's not true
it's it's a belief that this is all
because I really think a lot of it is
because he's a gay dude but that's not
true like because we've never seen that
we've never seen someone quote unquote
and like I said I do not identity John
not gay yeah but I don't identify little
Naz X and Elton John is the same because
in some conversations people consider
him
hip-hop even though I don't I consider
him a pop artist but that raps he's he's
certainly the first quote-unquote person
that raps that's on a level that he's on
that is openly gay but nobody nobody
listen he's still as much as much as
people care
if the reason you separate him and Elton
John because Elton John's [ __ ] is really
good I mean Elton John makes way better
music than little Nas X but one thousand
percent but that's my point so again
it's easy and that's what everybody's
doing like it's always the re if you if
you're critical of his brand if you're
critical of his art the immediate turn
is oh you're just homophobic you don't
lie cause you're gay let's actually
unpack the [ __ ] records let's unpack
the visuals they're not they're
executing his videos are fire but but
they're executed well but they're he's
not making ground
I mean the video game demo was kind of
crazy that's not even making ground
we've seen that before right but what it
is is he's just wrapping it up in gay
face like how Burgers right that's fair
like Bert Williams wrapping up in Black
and he's a black man this is black okay
so he's wrapping it up and he's doing
Britney Spears in gay face I like pad
net gay face gay face he's just gay like
blackface he's gay face
so he's just over dragging some [ __ ]
right he over dragon and just like that
shower scene is Christina Aguilera
that's they shot that before that that's
been done but you just used a bunch of
gay black men you just did it in gay
face because he's a gay guy but no but
it's not because he's a gay guy he knew
everybody would care about that see gay
people ain't just running around just
being extra just like black people ain't
it's black people that's dark as
blackface right it's this dark ass
people with red lips
right but people ain't just running
around just being a [ __ ] you know we
actually it's not as simple right so
when you see a black man right that's
what makes his thing he's a gay man but
because he's
unbelievably at a thousand we're trying
to tell you I'm gay bro we know you are
I'm not saying nothing wrong nobody give
a [ __ ] Elton John's gay right all kind
of people we end up loving is gay nobody
[ __ ] cares like right you sure you
care a little bit Prince was probably
bisexual I think everybody know that but
on the same token is it not like
it's his art right so if he wants to be
a Trailblazer for his his community that
you know he's really true that's not
true no I think I think if you think
about it's like saying Bert Williams is
Trailblazer blackface with black because
but I don't know who burp Williams is
he's the he's the biggest you told me so
again I wouldn't call him a Trailblazer
because you're not gonna have
generations of no no I just mean in
terms of like
I can't think of a time in the last 25
to 30 years that I've been alive and
paying attention to music that there's
been an openly gay Superstar not talking
about Adam Lambert or somebody who don't
really matter I'm talking about a super
little Nazi Superstar and
and what I'll so you and I had a
discussion about that video with the
devil sure and what I appreciated about
the video was his explanation for was
essentially
everyone
yeah my whole life was she said I'm
going to hell blah blah blah blah blah
all this clown [ __ ] really was just like
this is a good idea to make people talk
and it worked but again again I can
isn't that a lot of this [ __ ] though
yeah but isn't that a lot of this [ __ ]
agree 100 but then it got to be good at
the it got to be great at the root see
the but great at the root to you is
integrated at the root to maybe a 17
year old kid who loves all love great
records but what I'm saying is I think
little Nas X has some records that are
I'm out here around live what you mean
you're damn lie Old Town wrote his best
record and you know it oh for sure but
that's the problem like
um but holiday is a dope record
um Panini is a banger Panini's a banger
it's decent that [ __ ] is a banger it
bangs but it's not really but like what
I'm saying is like out here a little
nausea like Panini all right little
nazex Panini I'm like oh this [ __ ] is
tough oh it's Tim records in bro we're
talking it's Old Town Road is better
than every song of course it's the big
it's probably the biggest song of the
last 20 years but you're missing the
point of what I'm saying we've demanded
greatness from everybody we we we're not
allowed to say this about nobody else
sorry you saying greatness objective to
what you think is great well that's the
point right it's my perspective 100
right so if but what I don't want is my
opinion to be discounted about art or
brand because you think I'm a homophobe
or you think I care which is not the
case and that's what I'm dealing with
and that's what I don't like I don't
care that the man is gay I don't give a
[ __ ] how many if the [ __ ] shower
scene where they was dancing naked was
fire it'd be [ __ ] fire
it just wasn't good it was just corny
just [ __ ] corny so let me ask you
this
do you think was it Single Ladies
no of course not
again so I'm so now I'm looking at him
like okay you went through all this to
show this [ __ ] subpar routine so let
me ask you this
I think that there is a conversation to
be had though don't you think a lot of
the hate that he gets is rooted in some
homophobia though sure so I'm not
talking about you sure sure some people
are not they cannot
they cannot accept the they don't
understand a lifestyle enough and and
it's confusing to them because they have
their own belief of how this is
happening right I've had conversations
with people that they feel like oh you
can't be boring it's a thousand things
about people don't understand versus me
well I just don't care I just don't have
a reason you have an opinion on what
he's doing and you think it's corny
ain't got nothing to do with nothing
else bro I don't
man
people could speak up for me and I stop
them when they try I don't need nobody
to speak for me I don't I don't want you
to oh you know geez my boy in it I don't
say [ __ ] let me [ __ ] these [ __ ]
they can think what they want to think
his [ __ ] is corny I told him your shit's
corny you are black you owe some more so
maybe you don't think so but I am
demanding it as a fan you went through
all this to get to my attention you
dancing on the devil's lap and snap the
man neck you slide look like a fairy
you're doing all this [ __ ] you doing for
me to see you because you want to show
me all these visions of masculinity that
don't I'm not used to sing especially
from black men right you want to show me
this so you get my attention you make
the Satan shoes you already know black
people rooting in some level of
spirituality we don't [ __ ] with Satan
but you do it anyway so you get my
attention then you come back you got the
shower scene I've been to jail feel me
you dancing with the dudes in the shower
in the sub part number that's just you
should have actually had a fire number
at least so I could be pumped up about
it right
so you go through this to get my
attention you get it and then I give you
my opinion on your brand and your art
and you try to wrap it up and say like
I'm a homophobe you asked me to look at
it I looked at it here's what I'm
telling you that's what I think about it
now you could take it and say oh gee
you're being homophobia but whatever
clown [ __ ] [ __ ] Elton John mocks the
floor Sam Smith mops the floor with your
slow ass I don't disagree so if you're
not trying to be that good don't come
[ __ ] with my attention
so let me ask you this when you tweeted
that
he's more a tool for white supremacy or
a puppet rather because it matters then
lgbtq what do you mean by that he's a
[ __ ] entertainment piece for
mainstream America like puppets he's the
show and when you say white supremacy
yeah because at the highest level of
people looking right at the white
Supreme this is the top level of this
country right who knows if people are
embarrassed who knows of everything he's
their entertainment piece
feel me like you said he's a one of one
right and he he know everybody that
looked like me is shrinking down in
their seats like oh man and it's not
everybody is not just because you gay
it's just your shit's corny sometimes
again man when you black it's not fair
right it's not fair but there's things
expected of you and I'm not demanding
more than you then I wouldn't demand
from Prince or any other great artists
you feel me you don't get off because
you gay
you don't get off because you you still
expect it well guess what [ __ ] you got
to carry two torches
don't make us look stupid like you don't
make them people look stupid
um
feel me so I think he's doing a bad job
of making people look yeah I mean he
just doing it goofy like you're not
really adding to the culture you're not
creating a trend of things that's gonna
happen you gotta dig deep
bro you went through some real struggles
if you're a young black gay man you went
through some real struggles for sure can
I get that of course can I stop getting
these generic records that are not like
you're making bad versions he's making
pop records he's not making anything
with substance or depth to them as far
as like him talking about like
really tapping into the struggle God at
least be back Streets back is good
I mean that I mean look he got one he
got the little uh the hotel road is is
on fire I mean you know but now but like
damn we like eight or nine then we'd had
about four like come on that's what I
said I never heard a whack little nasak
song
no no he's too good to make a wax jump
at this point like he's a good artist
like he makes records I'm not saying
he's made anything better than the Old
Town Road
but I'm like yo I'm not I'm not riding
around bumping little nice X at all but
if I if I'm like I'll check his video
and I'll be like oh yeah get it you know
it's a pop record great writers you know
whatever it is but I don't think it's
I think it could be better and you're
right it could be so I everything could
be better but but so then we all should
demand it but you're right he's not
talented like Bruno Mars though but but
I'm saying Bruno Mars an alien yeah have
you seen that man live yeah but again
it's still like it's still pop like it's
not I know it is but Bruno Mars is like
one of the most talented artists that
we've seen in the last like 50 years
like like he's I love Bruno with live
scores day his life shows insane no more
I'm I'm somehow there's more I'm talking
about that level but I'm saying what
makes his [ __ ] dope is he's just not he
don't look like me and he's doing that I
think Bruno I think he's ill now Bruno's
an alien but but
again John's an alien put him in front
of that piano now see that's what I'm
talking about now no disrespect because
Bruno was [ __ ] fire and he got fired
he got some of the best rep see I
wouldn't say he's one of the best 50
like artists of the 50 years
I wouldn't even say that I'd say he has
some of the best records I've heard in
50 years he's one of the best performers
in the last 50 years I haven't seen that
but oh man technology is number one on
that list for me I agree but but at
least he was I I I haven't seen it nine
Peak technology so right Elton John
right that's fire
that's fine that's Uncharted
Uncharted Territory fire I don't
disagree filming Sam Smith
Uncharted Territory fight I think Sam
Smith is fire
now with that being said I probably
would rather listen to a little NASDAQ
song than a Sam Smith songs I don't want
to slice my wrist the only person the
only I listen to ever stay with me more
than ever stay with me this [ __ ]
incredible record okay stay with me is
incredible okay I'll give you that
little nose X is never gonna make a
record it's gonna stay with me why not
because he's not that talented that and
hence my point little not Sam Smith has
a voice of an Angel little guys a
SoundCloud rapper turned pop star but
then you got to just with great writers
but you got to Define it you got to
Define it because we can't hold little
nazex who literally is a SoundCloud
rapper no he's a pop star started as a
SoundCloud rapper and he's evolved into
a pop star
but he was first record his first record
he's not a great no little that [ __ ] was
a joke but it's still a pop record okay
fair enough but it was a joke so now you
got to compete with Bruno Mars that's
your lane everyone got to be Town hey
how about this let me give you an
example
now I'm not saying that Eminem is
culturally prevalent in the last 15
years right but can we agree that
technically Eminem is a top ten and 10
would be short-sighting him but if if I
were to say Eminem lyrically
gills as a rapper his top 10 all time
you would be like yeah of course yeah
but I mean great of course right of
course right sure top five
five for sure yeah you got too much
greatness 100 right now
I'm not over here barking down on
I don't even want to say little baby
because he's improved so much as a
rapper I'm not barking down on
um
Ghana
if Gunna got a hot record in the club or
got a number one record at Irving
because
he's not
as talented as someone like Eminem not
at the time they're not the same but
that's what I'm saying they're not but
good they're not the same but again
right what makes us all even
all of us right in in hip-hop or all of
us in pop music or all of us in any of
these genres the records so again so
you're saying record for record
that's all you have to be that's fair
you don't got to be his talented a song
like hot by Young Thug and gonna right
he's like a record that makes sense in
the club it's a cool record it was
number one at Urban radio
but it's not [ __ ] but I'm only asking
it's not it's it's not the box but but
I'm not asking it to be the box right
I'm asking it to be ha it's not it's
it's not high I'm ass but it's not but
but again right so but that don't mean
that it ain't dope but I don't mean that
it ain't good that don't mean that it
can't be in the same world like no I'm
not getting little ain't gonna he can't
do what Sam Smith does no but he can
make records as great as Sam Smith I
mean maybe yes I mean he has I mean look
I'm not as stupid I'm not as great as
Eminem right as technically sound as
Eminem but that don't mean I can't make
a record as that brings with one of his
records as Stan no I don't disagree with
you it's about doing the work
so at the end of the day your thoughts
on little Nas X are strictly rooted in
you're not crazy about the records he's
putting out and you think the execution
is corny well I think yeah I think the
records are decent they're above average
they're not you know what they're above
average that's fair to say compared to
all the records today but then again I'm
also on a court competing against Magic
Johnson like I'm looking at all of our
opportunities as modern day artists to
compete with the greatest records to
ever come out so I look at it
differently
um you'll know it's corny he knows it's
corny whether you admitted or not it's
cool you don't got it I see why you
think it's corny I look at it as
you know when we like like you know
what's going on no I mean I I'm but I
also you see sometimes you know but I'll
come from the era of watching Eminem
videos that were corny me too and I'd
say they was corny sometimes they were
[ __ ] corny what I'm saying so when I
look at that it kind of when I see
little and I was X putting his videos
out so something I think content isn't
corny of course oh my God oh my God he
was corny as [ __ ] so then why are you
struggling to say Lil Nas X content is
corny I'm not saying it's not but what
I'm saying if anything just say it I
don't to me it's not so none of the
content is corny but Eminem because when
I see no because when I watch The Devil
video I actually thought that was fire
I'm saying now maybe a prison [ __ ] is it
corny or not
to me for me prison [ __ ] is not corny I
didn't I the corniest [ __ ] I thought it
was refining and refreshing no I just
thought it was all this is cool this
reminds me some TRL errors it was cool I
wasn't mad at it to be honest 100 you
know it's corny you don't want to say
it's corn I'm just being honest with you
I think probably it was corny
it don't mean you're homophobe because
you think it's important I don't mean
I'm a racist
and it don't mean I'm a racist because I
think some of Eminem [ __ ] is corny no
and I'm not a sellout if I think early
days of pills sometimes you want to know
what the difference is sure and why I
can't say it's corny it's because I
expect corny [ __ ] from Little nazex
because he's a pop star
Eminem was a pop star every time we got
to The Real Slim Shady yeah but I was
listening to Eminem on sound bombing too
brockus records you just said the same
thing Lil nazek started as a SoundCloud
rapper you know what I'm saying is
little Naz X's first record don't you
see something that she'd be like
[Music]
his first record ever was corny as [ __ ]
so this is his bar he's a corny guy
he's on break I'll say the record is
corny
the video could have been corny but not
the record the record was coming I mean
it was I got her horses in the back it's
corny but but but it worked because it
was great but but it wasn't he set a
corny bar from the rip and it's just
been consistent no that's who he is that
record is not cool
I got the horses in the he literally
faked a country accent on the song great
record but no but if you executed
correctly he did then it's not corny
that's the thing like right like Adam
Sandler right is is one of my favorite
you know what I mean I love animals in
Hollywood right
the water boy trades the line so you
could tread the line of sometimes being
you gotta hit it but if you go too far
it'll get caught you know what about
Adam Sandler is the same way but listen
but listen I think Adam Sandler I expect
corny [ __ ] so when he does like uh the
Zohan movie which is super corny then
you say it's cool I appreciate it so why
did you just laugh but again me too but
I appreciate little Nas extra [ __ ]
because I expect it to be cool you won't
say it's corny no I just said I expected
to be coordinated
the corner of Cornelius his whole career
is corny
say
that shower scene in that video I don't
think that shower scene was corny do I
think that
I'm being honest do I think this song
was corny maybe yeah
so what's corny besides his complete
idea just the song's called industry
baby and like it's like yeah okay that's
a low-hanging fruit for a little Nas X
to make a song about being the industry
plant okay I get it and then the video
is what I expect which is why it's not
corny still you gotta be good I did it
listen as much as Adam Sandler right can
be corny The Waterboy is amazing and
it's not corny I love The Waterboy Zohan
is amazing because but but no sometimes
you can go but sometimes you can go too
far corny don't necessarily mean that's
not good I am not listening to little
Naz X's music
obviously subject you don't listen to
pop music me well let's just like Bruno
it got to be elite level I'm not
listening to little Naz X in my car ever
yeah I I threw on his EP when it dropped
the was it called the Rodeo EP
right just to just to listen to it I
threw it it was like five songs all
right cool did you hear the record with
cardi B that was cool but I am not
riding around in my car pressing play on
middle and I was X ever what I can do as
someone who's
appreciates entertainment I can look and
see what he's doing and be like I get it
now it's not for me why not because it's
just not I'm also do not enjoy some pop
music
not most of it to be fair do you enjoy
some
do you like Bruno Mars I love Bruno Mars
that's pop okay so some if that's some
sure do you enjoy Sam Smith no I'm not
listening to I mean yeah Elton John yeah
of course I love them show the best of
the best pop music I love it Elton John
yeah I mean I mean yeah I mean I like
like 70 [ __ ] 80 [ __ ] I mean not even 80
best of the best I'm not big on 80s pop
music there's a lot of pop music out
there but I'm not a big 80s pop guy I
actually think 80s pop is corny as [ __ ]
but but that means you don't like I
don't like NSYNC I never like Backstreet
Boys I never like none of that that's
90s that's nice I know but I'm saying I
never liked any of that [ __ ] so when
people are like like Justin Bieber
peaches right good records that's an r b
record right it's fire great record now
it's not corny though I no no you're
right it's fire that's a beautifully
Written song it's probably executed
executed perfect again
I'm not driving around in my car bumping
peaches I'd play peaches too now if
peaches comes on you're not gonna change
the channel I'm not gonna change it
which if if that industry baby
I might change it so I'm not so get
where that's we're talking we're getting
a point but we're green on the same
thing well not for me to say it was bad
it's just not good neither is Peaches
but you would not change it because the
pictures is a better song that's what
I'm saying teachers is a way better
peaches is better than I'm upset Sonic
there's been a lot of songs I'll take
peaches more than I mean that's a
[ __ ] perfect song sure I know you
don't complain to me that [ __ ] fire I
love uh you know like there's like
records like that I love to play like in
the club like Essence by Wizkid [ __ ]
love it right it's a great [ __ ]
Justin Bieber just jumped on the remix
now I'm probably not driving around in
my car listening to whiz she's not gonna
change if it came of course not so all
I'm demanding is better record and
better representation from Lil Nas X I'm
not asking for much I'm not saying hey
don't be gay you're gay bro that's how
it is I don't give a [ __ ] it's not my
[ __ ] business but when you sh when
you get my [ __ ] attention you
go through all this [ __ ] for me to find
out and I give you my opinion deliver
[ __ ] right deliver my [ __ ] don't
oh all I'm not even talking about the
song I'm talking about this bro go to
the next level that's all I'm saying
that's what's expected you you you nine
ten records deep at this point let's get
to it now what do you think do you think
the baby can do anything to um
patch up his
current Optics with um they'll be
booking them at the festivals in a year
in a year you think it'll be fine I
think it just jumps on a little nozek
song and it's all good he definitely
shouldn't do that you don't think you
should do that no
little Nas X the baby on the remix bro
that the baby actually has this
authentic feel Lil Nas X lacks
authenticity
they can help each other bro go to Elton
John get Elton John go get Sam Smith is
in your hook don't [ __ ] with him he's a
[ __ ] cornball make him dig himself
out of corny first come back to the rest
of the you know the depth [ __ ] your
brother come back to the depth of it
feel me then we [ __ ] with it but then
if if you're going to do something you
worried about how the lgbtq community
sees you go get a big dog go Elton John
get Sam Smith go sit down with Sam let
him sing a beautiful hook to the ladies
or sing a beautiful hook to the fellas
whoever's the [ __ ] just sing a love hook
and you rap with go to the best don't
[ __ ] with him he's a [ __ ] cornball he
got to get his [ __ ] together I demand
better he can do it too I heard Old Town
Road there's something in there he just
gotta let me ask you this too so like on
the other side of the coin there's guys
like Boosie right who's one of my
favorite dudes in in the game every time
I talk to him he's his I know what I'm
getting he's hilarious but at the same
time he also comes across the little
homophobic he has a genuine fear and and
and and and obviously I don't think it's
for him at least because I I'd like to
think I've been around him enough to
know that he's not a hateful guy sure
but I do think that there's like a um
a big part of hip-hop in the industry
where there's people behind the scenes
or whatever that that kind of share his
opinions about
just the the homosexuals in general and
and I'm I'm a believer that if you're
gay
you were going to be gay anyway
I I wouldn't say that but I think there
are some people that are born gay and I
also think like if
somebody like little nazex being openly
gay as an African-American man in this
country which as you acknowledged
earlier probably one of the hardest
things to be in this world as a black
man let alone a black guy oh God because
then you're [ __ ] in your own community
on top of being [ __ ] in America sure
right so if little nazette's standing on
that
um openly and proudly helps inspire
people to be themselves more right to be
more proud of who they are or to live
their truths louder or more proudly
isn't that a good thing
I mean but again yes right unless you
believe that he's actually infiltrating
people's minds and turning them gay
which I don't think is in this case I
had this I've been having this dilemma
in this conversation right because I
used to feel the same way I do not think
you could just play gay like it is for
some man to take penis bro is a
different kind of devotion like you have
to be committed it's gonna be tough even
like Bruce Jenner I mean or Kailyn
whatever right even then he's still not
gay
no right right he's a lesbian he became
a lesbian right right so I think it's a
different commitment so I felt the same
way you did I felt like you can't get
people to be gay but
that might not be true that could be
wrong it can be a lot more influential
than we are we want to admit we're in a
really weird place in society where
social media is controlling a lot of
things and attention talk too man but in
general all of it is controlling a lot
people are dying for attention like
they're in a really weird space so the
things people will do to get attention
that could be a problem so that's why
that I agree with you on that because so
so again like
as much as I wanted to kind of look at
them like bro
it is something to be scared of I think
this right I think people will do things
for attention now more than ever but at
the same time like you said to be a gay
person is a big commitment right so I
think if you were going to
you know be attracted to men and be in
romantic relationships
and Mom oh man but what I'm saying is
that personally I think you just really
have to be committed that's a lot no so
what I'm saying is is like those people
were gonna probably feel that way inside
anyway maybe they were going to get
married to a woman that they hated or
that they secretly you know what I'm
saying like I think they don't know if
that's necessarily true I think we all I
think both sides at that point we will
all be speaking from ignorant places but
we also can't deny the control and
influence I think there's a there's a
there's definitely a such thing as
saying that there's an attention thing
going on which is where I like I think
like and and I'm not and again I'm not
accusing any
you know homosexual part I genuinely
think this is what's going on but I
can't ignore right now we're in one of
the most
scariest times of society where
everybody is following you know I mean
for attention because everything about
our life is built on what is it called
uh societal acceptance or societal uh
you know whatever that is the wealth of
it I think the way I look at it right
when like boozy says some [ __ ] it to me
it kind of makes me cringe because I'm
like man like the only way you're really
scared of this is if you truly believe
little nazex can turn a child gay and he
and I think genuinely they believe it
and and I think genuinely boozy thinks
that that's the I genuinely one I for
sure because he definitely believed us
and I didn't but now I'm standing like
okay I see what you're saying because
you can turn a child into a gangster you
can turn the child yeah you can turn the
child into a racist that's true so again
it's all a lifestyle change it's all a
lifestyle thing I don't know I think
it's about like what you're attracted to
I think is kind of built into you I
guess I would like to believe that but
man that might not be true
I I I would like to believe that's true
but again this is one of them
conversations that Society wanted me to
be attracted to white women sure in my
entire life I've not [ __ ] with any
white women because they just don't do
it for me
that's racist though no it's not I mean
I'm just being honest with you as a
child what did I grow up watching what
was on TV Baywatch well who was on
Sports Illustrated covers [ __ ] uh
what was the bitch's name so you've
never seen a white lady you want to know
I mean I I can like see a white chick
and be like yeah she's cute you know but
like so you've not for me and a white
lady you thought was absolutely gorgeous
of course so then what are we talking
about is there not men in this world
that you can be like that's a good
looking dude never you've never seen a
guy and been like yo he's a good looking
guy never never been attracted to a guy
I didn't say attracted to I said can you
have not ever been attracted to a white
woman you've never been attracted to a
white woman when I was a little kid I
think Pamela Anderson was hot but then I
started
Megan Good is not hot
it's not for me
that is crazy wait Megan good yeah Megan
Megan Fox oh yeah Megan Fox no her
thumbs kill me she's got short thumbs
plus that's that's MGK's home uh that's
MGK's girl that's my dog so but no no no
[ __ ] he know he's a little fox
I can acknowledge she's a beautiful
woman but it's not for me
yeah see that's the point right somebody
probably wouldn't believe you somebody
once I discovered JLo as a child
it was over it was just like latinas and
then and then Tyra Banks and I was like
oh this is different I don't want to
[ __ ] nobody who looks like they could be
related to me
laughs
yeah like you don't feel me I've never
heard that but this is definitely
special but again right so I can
acknowledge a white chick looks like
yeah she's beautiful but if you don't
want to nail her if you're not attracted
to it I mean
listen what I'm saying is
I should be
in the white girls not really
you don't have to be
all I'm saying is right maybe
okay so I can see the comp but again I
don't know if I can just at one time I
was certain of it but kind of thinking
I'm not sure it could be a little bit
more influential I say all the gay
people I know with with and this is
people who are actually gay who actually
suck dick and get their dick sucked by
men and you know God bless them friends
of mine sure yeah yeah
um say that this is something that they
knew as soon as they were conscious of
of Attraction and that this is like this
I know the homies told me the same thing
that I know so so based on what gay
people say but I've heard other gay
people say different I've heard other
gay people talk about things that have
happened to them
I usually getting molested as children I
mean I I mean that I'm gonna say [ __ ]
them up maybe and again but I I do know
but again we are coming into Uncharted
territories in society at this point
where influence and and social wealth I
mean social uh
uh social specific word but now they're
at all time high I think there's the
all-time thing about right now
is rappers wearing dresses yeah that was
like 10 years ago yeah but um uh
I mean Andre did that that's what I'm
saying so so now we're he wore killed
that's not fair yeah but Andre also just
fashionably was just super forward but
people clowned him back but a kilt steel
is okay Young Thug wore a dress on the
cover of an album and a guy wore a
wedding dress in a video yep right so
again
we're doing things for attention how
about this Dennis Rodman wore a dress
right married himself yes we're doing so
do we think that that made other people
gay well I don't think I don't think
that's I don't I don't I don't think he
inspired people to be to wear dresses
yes I mean maybe yeah I think people
buried themselves up how about this
though do you think that Young Thug
wearing a dress if anything
first of all people were refer to date
homies as my love do people refer to
themselves as having dicks out their gun
yes he's an influential figure he's a
very talented gifted yeah but I don't
think he's influencing anyone to Sakai
because he's not necessarily on record
sucking [ __ ] if he's sucking do you
think little Naz X is influencing people
to suck dick I don't know I he never
influenced me that's what I can tell you
but again
you're asking me right I don't think
that I think if my kids saw me but it's
not crazy for Bootsy to think kids could
want to follow success and wealth
and they may think success and wealth
could come with sucking dick if they're
looking at little Nas X
it might sound asinine the thought of it
but we are in a different I watched
somebody the other day kill somebody
over a pair of shoes and a raffle that
was insane 16 year old kid you're
missing no the 16 year old kid is who
killed the guy but but you're missing
the point of what where we at so to keep
ignoring we're in different spaces feel
me and and and you got to be careful
what you're saying is that we're on in
Uncharted Territory as far as social
media being so prevalent and that might
be fair I think too like
now it's also almost like you know where
there's so much
opinion and and and [ __ ] all around
everybody right you open your phone you
just scrolling on Tick Tock whatever the
algorithm feeds you it's gonna make you
feel some type of way you know what I'm
saying
you know I got my niece is uh she just
came out as non-binary she's 14 years
old I don't even know what that is so I
know what it is but I was like that [ __ ]
is crazy right so I want you to identify
me as either anything so the day them
thing is another thing that's like
you know I had a conversation with my
boy Ramses about this recently and he
was like and I was to the point where I
was like look I'm so down if you're if
you're born a male and you're like
I I decided I want to be a female so
call me she all right cool the day them
thing just breaks my brain a little well
because because it sounds like I'm
talking to multiple people because of
language the irony is right I'm a
transfer right and people get upset and
I'm like bro I'm just telling you the
truth I have a genuine fear of trans
people it's confusing to me and it blows
my mind and they never go to the
complete other side enough to where even
the the ones that go all the way over is
just like that's a lot for me I mean for
my brother something that that doesn't
it's just confusing I'm confused so
you're oh you're openly saying you're
transphobic yes okay I've said this
multiple times and people get mad at me
don't you bring up me because I'm scared
the [ __ ] you want me to do I see that
[ __ ] I haven't had any conversations
with any trans people no and that's what
I'm trying to set up on my podcast
because I'm trying to have a better
understanding I don't think they're
gonna kill me it's just a scary thought
the confusion worries do you think being
confused and being scared or separate or
kind of the same
because scared is like or Tran you know
when we hear the word transphobic fear
means danger right so so the the danger
would be right if if
for most black men you would be worried
that you're gonna run into a woman that
was a man
right that before previously right you
could have had the the Johnson sliced
off could have got the breast all the
female hormones but you still don't want
that to happen to you that's a big thing
I wouldn't want that to happen to me
that would bother me so you want to have
an open conversation with someone who's
from the trans Community I understand
yeah because I do think that there are
people who genuinely
decide like I'm not this and in order
for me to be happy and fulfilled I have
to live my life this way and I respect
that concept completely and all of those
other Concepts right the problem is when
you start trying to change what I see
that's my problem so I think that the
the
see that that's what I don't like this
is what I think I think that like you're
at least open enough to where you can
say
I truly am confused about what this is
and have a genuine fear and I genuinely
would like to sit down and have a
dialogue with someone sure who is from
that Community because I would like to
understand it more and I think that that
is where what you're saying is different
than probably a lot of the hate and
bigotry and negativity that someone who
is in the trans Community or someone who
did grow up
um as I could maybe a a trans 17 or 18
year old
they experienced that word transphobic
in a different way that probably means
violence hate them hatred
you know their health being at risk you
know uh discrimination sure you're
saying it in in terms of hey look the
actual definition really this is a
language thing it means you know like
you said danger fear right and and I
wouldn't say that you probably fear for
your life no but you don't understand it
sure and so you're I think what's yours
because I don't want people to be like
glasses one says he's transmitted they
can say that I'm I'm okay with being who
I am and honest about who I am but but
what the difference is is like with that
word comes and whether or not we like to
say this is what it says in the
dictionary what that word comes a lot of
other stuff attached to it so what being
I don't think I don't think you're a
bigot not I would never hell no and I
don't think you're a hateful person of
course I hate some people and if I don't
think you're a hateful person though I
don't think you're I don't think you're
in your your first nature is not being a
hateful guy no but but I don't think I
don't think that's even the worst racist
Concepts I think it's all rooted in
ignorance right we're all ignorant
that's right that's right if you're
scared if if you're arachnophobic right
or you have Arachnophobia right you're
scared of spiders it's because you don't
understand you may think all spiders are
venomous you may think they could bite
you you may think all of that but if you
obviously right if you informed yourself
or if you were educated it would bring
some level
I also don't want to compare spiders to
trans people because trans people aren't
poisonous they're just neither they're
just [ __ ] spiders but a lot of
spiders are not even a lot the majority
aren't but but see how you just did that
see I just see that's the thing with
human being nobody trans is poisonous
but but again if if let's say if it's a
a man who was a woman like a man right
who be became a woman right that's going
out of her way because there is some
sleeping with guys who she doesn't
disclose that she is and she know that
could crush them
that is dangerous now I'm not that is
dangerous but I'm saying I don't
disagree with you but I'm saying that's
not all of their agendas just like with
spiders their agenda is not to poison
everybody so the part the point um that
you would like to try to understand and
sitting down with someone would be some
of the
I guess the concept of like why
why you're deciding to live your life
this way what is well I think I I get it
right
the idea of it makes sense to me right
okay if you really feel like even though
I could never relate I have no idea but
if if you felt you are a woman your
whole life and you were a man and you
felt that way I don't think I want to
understand how did you feel that way I
don't think that's the point
um which part of of it
is is confusing to you that baffles you
no once it happens the fact that you
want me to see you different
that's the thing that [ __ ] me up so let
me ask you this right if someone says to
you
and I'm not saying cook on the couch
over there all of a sudden says hey I'm
a woman call me she or I'm Gonna Cancel
you ready but let's say you meet someone
who's
let's say
you grew up around somebody you ain't
seen them in 10 years yeah and you see
them and they've transitioned to a woman
I'm not saying that this has happened
which obviously hasn't happened man you
know that person
as however you know that person right
but but
if they tell you hey look glasses
it will make me feel much better
it makes me if you if you refer to me as
this
if you refer to me as he or you refer to
me as my old name it hurts it it [ __ ]
me up and and obviously we can't tell
anybody how to feel right pain is pain
isn't that a minor inconvenience for you
to make someone feel all right
and I'm not saying it's your job to make
anyone feel all right well that's the
thing right I would do whatever
convenient I would never just because as
much as I'm a transfer right which I
wouldn't go over I wouldn't walk up to
to Bruce to Caitlyn rather I wouldn't
call that like I wouldn't I'm not going
out of my way back oh your mom name you
boost I'm a name you I just I'm not
right feel me I just wouldn't even [ __ ]
with that person now if it's one of my
best friends I'm gonna call him whatever
he asking me to call him at or she's
ever asking me to call him at that point
but I would be uncomfortable while I'm
uncomfortable is is I don't quite know I
don't know I'm being honest with you I
have no idea why it's almost crazy
because I'm my fears is usually I could
you know see why but you know this one
is weird I'm not a homophobe but also
when people call I laugh well I don't
know I think it's I think it's dope to
just hear you say that like you're open
to having hey look this is how I feel
but I want to have a conversation with
somebody in the community because but
that's what my podcast was all about
for me I don't like to live in ignorance
it bothers me I hate being afraid of
that [ __ ] I ain't being afraid of
anything I love conquering my fear I
think what we also have to understand
um and what it's been harder for me to
understand it recently to really tell I
had a conversation recently with one of
my best friends
um
is not everything
has to make sense that makes sense no
that doesn't make sense because when you
start when you start trying to make
everything make sense and it's not a
plight or something that you can
identify with and it just don't make
sense to you
some [ __ ] just don't gotta make sense
but I think see and that's where I think
as a thinking man right that's why I'm
used to the world making sense
so when sometimes things happen that
don't make sense right or or out of my
realm of understanding right right I shy
away that makes sense I mean that makes
sense and and but it also now I get some
people get angry and get you know that's
they get hateful they get violent they
get bigoted yeah no you're like yo I'ma
just shy away yeah but I'm willing to
have a conversation to help and and
pursuing the idea right and pursuing the
idea
um
the character Uncle Clifford I don't
know if that would be you know if Uncle
Clifford's character because I think the
character is a man but I don't know if
that's referred to as a trans or
crossdresser I don't know the property I
don't even know what that is uh so Uncle
Clifford is a character from uh P Valley
I don't even know people he owns a strip
club right oh is that oh I heard about
it it's
um it's a Mississippi based it's a black
strip club I heard about it it's on
Stars yeah it's fire okay okay but this
character is one of the best layered
characters right for that Community see
that's a great character written for
that community that character is [ __ ]
accidentally written and that's what I'm
asking and that's what human beings need
I mean like if it like okay it's cool to
have some that plan to stereotype but
then give something that people can
really understand with and be empathetic
towards just because you exist see
naturally the act of being a human being
right is to be empathetic being Humane
but it don't come with every model that
that's born on this earth right so you
have to give them figures and characters
that's why I don't mind them implicating
you know things in in adult films about
you know because it'll make you like
like I said Uncle Clifford like that
[ __ ] helped me a lot like I'm like damn
that [ __ ] cool I [ __ ] with that
I need to have a conversation with that
[ __ ] he might actually be this
character even if you think like um
I mean even think about
Omar little in The Wire I never watched
The Wire oh there's another conversation
right I never watched it but but but
this character is written so well that's
crazy yeah this character's written so
well that you know what I mean that's
that's the point I'm saying I think I
think um
we can use entertainment and a lot of
things to our advantage but we have to
be careful with how we do it you know we
just can't throw anything out I'm saying
that's the problem so
I I respect everybody being you know um
mindful of what they're doing right
especially in some of these places that
make a lot of people uncomfortable you
know let's show [ __ ] at people because
you always me are the right to exist
it's like you know I mean like It's just
tough that's not the wisest way to do it
if I made a racist white family I'm not
gonna walk in the house and watermelon
chicken and be the [ __ ] they want me to
be right see I'm gonna walk in the house
and be who I am
see that's and that's what I was saying
specifically about anything right it's
one thing that had these big stupid ass
glasses on it's another thing if I walk
in this [ __ ] with all these
stupid ass blue bandanas around my neck
wrist elbow over exaggerating I'm a [ __ ]
you know this is [ __ ] there are things I
could do several things I could do that
you'll notice Chris maybe I get it in
the side of my head you know these
glasses over the top all the time
becomes corny and Clowny right so but I
digress you know I'm saying that's the
thing you know being honest with who you
are like I'm not I'm not gonna fight no
[ __ ] trans person because aren't they
trans like what the [ __ ] I look like I'm
not fighting nobody I'm [ __ ] I mean
I'm not fighting nobody that ain't did
something wrong to me or deserve a ass
kicking now I mean listen man I think
your honesty is is is is great and I
think that more more people who
feel the way you feel because we
obviously know there's a lot of people
who feel that way and I don't think it's
necessarily rooted in a place of hate uh
it's rooted in a place of
misunderstanding and
um lack of you know experience or
education or whatever it is the fact
that like you're open to having those
conversations and sure yeah man [ __ ] I
mean that [ __ ] is big I don't think I
think it's normal for a thinking man I
just every part everybody else ain't got
time to think people just really living
their life on autopilot I'm a thinking
person I I like to think I like to
figure it out I like to be comfortable
it could be a lack of exposure yeah I
mean so yeah I mean look at the end of
the day right there's kids that are
being raised in communities that are
probably fully white right but but
that's been my point forever that have
no idea about black experience that
doesn't make them racist no not at all
it makes them racially ignorant probably
yeah what but but think about this think
about this right but that's why I say I
feel the same way about the word racism
it's thrown around entirely too much
everything to describe everything is
racist it's like just like everything
that's thrown around is a homophobic
transfer right bro you got to use that
word much better like every Community
needs to use these words much better
because to mislabel people it's actually
just kind of uh uh promoting the same
hate you you're going against but like
think about this I grew up in Phoenix
around I mean my immediate friend group
was African-American and Mexican right
but that was really the two minorities
in my life that I was raised around so I
never really experienced
um a lot of culture outside of Black
Culture Mexican culture or you know my
parents you know what I'm saying
um but like we went to New York
um
earlier this year and we're in a part of
Brooklyn
where it was a Hasidic Jew uh community
and that's something I never experienced
so I was like truly is that like is that
like out here like I said with the hats
so that's like out there Miracle Mile
probably yeah sure so so
um the homie we were with was like yeah
they got their own police force they
don't um on certain days they don't
touch a phone they don't touch buttons
like it's you know and they're like yo
they got their own ambulances you could
be on their street and get stabbed and
be bleeding to death and their ambulance
won't pick you up and it was just
telling me like a rundown of like the
Hasidic Jew culture and [ __ ] and I was
enamored I was like so intrigued because
this is something I never even knew was
a thing
like we're in New York and I'm like this
[ __ ] is ill should I've been in New York
and they were Spanish towns that was
racist but you know what I'm saying like
what I'm saying is like just in general
like like you were saying earlier like
yo you can't you you you lack of
exposure was the word you used right so
in the same way that we probably know
that there's kids being being raised in
white towns who don't know any black
people that's just their no no they
might have to go to college they might
have to you know if they're blessed
enough yeah go live their life but some
of them kids will never get out of that
[ __ ] Podunk town man I'd have been on
tour with tech N9 and been to towns you
could tell a dude told me I was the
third black person he ever met which is
crazy uh you would think in the 2000s
that's just a crazy concept but again
it's one of those things where I don't
waste my time trying to figure out you
know I'm not trying to change the world
I'm figuring out how to master myself
and help as many people and that's a
beautiful thing hey interrupting the
interview to tell you about our good
friends at Odd Socks now as you can see
I always have my Odd Socks on baby you
know what I'm saying ooh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddsoxofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are The Outsiders
you know what I'm saying they got
SpongeBob they got Cheech and Chong
listen Breaking Bad Godfather whatever
you need they got it and now they have
underwear that's right you can get your
Odd Socks underwear the boxer briefs are
the best underwear that you could ever
fit on your ass trust me when I tell you
these are Chucky draws what you know
about Top Ramen underwear all right go
to oddstocksofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg Kevin checkout and you'll save
20 off of of your order underwear masks
slippers socks whatever you need they
got it oddsoxofficial.com keyword
bootleg cabbage check out save 20
um you mentioned the [ __ ] thing and I
wanted to talk to you about this because
I know that you're
um one of the more highly respected guys
I've ever come across whenever I say oh
yeah I know Jim alone people like you
know what I'm saying you're yeah sure
from all walks of life if this if it was
possible it would be respected in this
code the gangster [ __ ] and also like
this [ __ ] guy and you've done you've
done Gathering of the Juggalos and all
that [ __ ] yeah you've been I mean I'm
sure you were signing the sub Noise
Records yeah yeah yeah yeah Madison
um but I wanted to get your take on
six nine and you know recently whack
because whack on my show said that he
didn't feel like six nine was a snitch
he said he felt like he was a civilian
who told the truth he's lying
it's about six knives a snitch so I
wanted to kind of get your take because
I know you and I have had a discussion
about the snitch [ __ ] and it's
essentially you know what do you define
as that
okay so the the flaw in wax discussion
with that is he's a civilian right so on
the west coast being a civilian means I
guess in theory you're not a part of a
gang you're not a part of the army the
Infantry whatever that is right based
off of the real word but everywhere else
that's a rooted in criminal like
snitching has nothing to do with gang
banging snitching is rooted in being a
criminal you know or murtha and all
these colds go back before Crips and
bloods or any gangs of Black Culture
existed in this country not snitching is
a thing in criminality like there are no
criminal will respect him no criminal
period will respect him and I just think
wax not a criminal
yet what he's saying is obviously not
true he knows
that boy is a rat that boy isn't right
there you know he's a rat it's only
you're not a rat if you're not a
criminal like if I did something to
somebody that's that's not a criminal
that's what they're supposed to do
inform the police if you do something to
a criminal he's not supposed to we all
know this
so because wax argument is rooted in
whether or not six nine is a gang member
he was a convicted pervert he was a drug
dealer before he ever met the Gang
so you're saying I mean and I don't
disagree with you that the snitch stigma
or the snitch definition what it what
makes someone a snitch is not rooted in
gang banging no it's not rooted in
whether or not you're a [ __ ] or a blood
or whatever it's rooted in being a
criminal world and he's a committed
criminal he's devoted to the the
lifestyle of being a criminal he just
told it's nothing
man that spin is is a good spin for the
average you know I'm saying the average
fan out there you know what I mean it's
a great spin for them but if you really
in the Life man he's a he's a rat he
know he a rat you think whack whack
knows he's a rat yes I got paid
you think whack got paid I know why I
got paid to do the interview why I got
paid whack is one of the smartest
[ __ ] I agree I met when it
comes to this music [ __ ] I agree whack
is a brilliant guy feel me he got paid
he might have got two or three checks I
wouldn't be surprised if it come out he
got a check because they talking about
promoting a fight I wouldn't be
surprised if cuz got a check from you
know Spotify for doing this [ __ ] with
academics I wouldn't be surprised if he
got a check from Lucian and Elliott for
promoting their artists and trying to
establish his brand well I got paid
it does feel like now six nine if he
were to like
release music right now or try to get
the music popping again
it does feel like that the whack thing
helped a lot as far as making it easier
for like you said surface level
consumers to cause to to swallow to
believe he has some level of credit
Integrity or credibility and he has none
he's a horrible human being do you think
like six nine is one of snitch not as
one of the worst human beings I've ever
encountered like Hitler bad
he's horrible
he literally is manipulative you know
he's one of the type of people that you
don't want to be around he's literally
full of [ __ ] he will do anything to be
to have attention right anything
to have attention and he's manipulative
he knows people aren't that bright so
he's taking advantage of it because
might be like Satan himself he's
manipulating the Mexican Community but I
said oh he's Mexican bro that dude is
full of [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] rat he's a
rat because he didn't want to deal with
the crimes he had other people do for
him that he paid other people he paid
him it has nothing to do with gang he
they didn't do it for free that's how
much they didn't respect him if they he
charged him if I call my homeboy to do
so they gonna do it for me period And I
wouldn't call him right right right
right he paid them he was a criminal
before them he'll be a criminal after
them right now he's a he's a working
informant like I'm looking at stuff 21
Savage and I'm doing talking about
fighting this man what are y'all
thinking man this man will get you put
in prison right now this ain't over you
don't just snitch one time on on a case
that big and get that little time he's a
permanent informant he's going to tell
for 20 or 30 years that man is a rat
whack no here rat everybody know you're
right do you I mean because I mean look
at the end of the day I I think whack
had a conversation with him in which he
held him as accountable as we've seen
someone hold him accountable I don't
know if you watched the interview I
wasn't there
um they'd be having Clubhouse well I
wouldn't be in the room listen I I I I I
I won't consume it's con I won't
consumers content I won't do nothing I
you know I gave him a chance initially I
[ __ ] with him I listened to his music
I didn't hear somebody
great records but bro once you once once
you are criminal and you break that code
again it's a sense of Ethics you have no
real ethics as a human being feel me
like I'm just not [ __ ] with you you
were [ __ ] let me ask you this with
whack like obviously like you said he's
one of the more brilliant guys I mean I
I got love for wack wax always been
solid with me do you think that
um he made a mistake by having that
conversation with six nine and and at
least I don't think he's aligning
himself with him in any capacity I think
they obviously have an open line of
communication I think wack held him
accountable in that interview at all but
essentially saying you're a snitch
like you know that music is corny he
know your snitch
so my question to you is like do you
think whack made a mistake even having
any sort of
you know conversation with that guy it
depends on what his values
I wouldn't have no conversation with
that [ __ ] for no amount of money
whack my value something different you
know I mean it could be money maybe he
never plans to be on Crenshaw Boulevard
another day in his life you know or or
he's not going or at the street races or
in some level of Street activity maybe
he's transitioning to a business World
none of the [ __ ] that I [ __ ] with on
no street level would ever do it even
the ones that's in this business they
will never do that I don't give a [ __ ]
what money none of us [ __ ] with that
rat period at all for me so the whack
make a mistake that's up to him he had
to Value whatever he benefited from
doing it but he knows that what he's
saying is definitely you know
um
he know he's a snitch he didn't he know
he he know the boys are right he know he
a rat it's obvious he's a rat he ratted
in front of everybody on paperwork
he's a rat it's obviously he's a rat you
know what I'm saying so whack would
probably be the person to ask if he made
a mistake I don't think he should have
did it I think whack making great money
you know but then I'm not in the man
Pockets I don't know what's important to
him I don't I don't know I mean even
knowing him I never sat down to say man
what's important to you even if like
let's say whack truly does believe he's
a civilian and doesn't feel like there's
no you don't think not one like one 17
he does not believe he's none of that
it's not about that whack no snitching
is nothing to do with games whack is is
as smart if not smarter than I am he
knows that why he's a snitch but he also
understands how to spin a story he's
really good at marketing he's really you
know good at what he does but he know
that boy as a snitch and because he is
representing pyrule because he is
representing blood I don't think he
should have did it at all because it's a
bad look for the culture for me
completely in my mind but whack is one
individual that represents whack when
it's said and done you know as much as
we all want to hold each other
accountable I'm going to keep being a
representation for the streets and all
the people that look to me and I'll
never sit down with that rat and if I'm
in I'm like making them on the phone
hold up I'm blowing
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] I'm not I'm getting
away from you feel me or if we got an
issue I'm gonna get cracking on you it
ain't it ain't nothing personal bro you
just a [ __ ] raggedy ass
evil ass [ __ ] shaking ass [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] use a [ __ ] listen I don't
disagree with you on on the kids
character I do think that what he kind
of did was
expose a lot of hip-hop to be exactly
that entertainment and I'm not talking
about with the whack thing I mean just
in general like when he got out of jail
and he I mean he seems to be moving
around rather nicely with no I mean I I
know people like like they overselling
it no no I know um so like he'd be with
a lot of YouTubers I've heard I've heard
what you're talking about I've heard
that right but he's a really
Sinister kid
he's and he's not a kid he's a really
sinistered grown ass man evil ass man
you know I'm saying he's a really
Sinister evil ass man he's really
Sinister he's really evil nothing about
him is cool nothing about him is good
him dying would be the best thing that
happened to his daughter that's how
[ __ ] up of a [ __ ] is he's a
horrible human being that's great this
family will be better off without him
he's that horrible like you don't meet
y'all don't see it it's hidden behind
all the [ __ ] and this rap [ __ ] or
you know he's exposed he's not he's evil
like he's a different level of sinister
and he's a coward and he's not willing
to be held accountable he's doing [ __ ]
where he know people can't get to him he
goes places in the middle of times when
he know people that he's not walking up
on people and if he's walking up on him
now it's because he has the support of
the Federal Bureau of Investigation
that's it nothing about him is good his
daughter would be better off without him
like I I I hope you feel me eventually
he understands how [ __ ] up of a
[ __ ] human being he is he's a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] rat and whack knows this
I'm whack knows whack notice he not he
know right right you know they know we
all know
um you've had a storied career in terms
of obviously your come up
um some of the labels you've been with
um some of the tours you've been on uh
you know I've I think I first had got
hip to you
um on one of the early Black Wall Street
mixtapes
um sounds about right I feel like that
yeah that's what I started
um rest in peaceful thing
um and then obviously you know from
there I you know you you end up with
cash money no
um cash money is a place and Birdman is
a guy who seems to be
he's a legend first of all when it comes
to just his tree is crazy probably the
goat when it comes to his tree his tree
or Dre's tree you gotta go
yeah Dre and Russ and and stunner
probably got the trees of all trees and
so
um
he's also a guy who's had some sort of
like you know polarized love-hate thing
going on the last 10 years or so when it
comes to like him what's perceived as
him maybe doing artists wrong so sign of
shitty contracts whatever the case is
right
how was your experience on cash money
great it was and I'm not saying it like
I have no fear none of no [ __ ]
right but the dude was great to me I
learned more [ __ ] than I ever knew about
the business
um I learned a ton man like it was
awesome to me today now let me ask you
this because you you also correct me if
I'm wrong were you also who banging as
well yeah same time Max in so because I
remember Mack 10 had Banger ball which
is one of the most slept on albums yeah
I like that record that album was
[ __ ] crazy
um and he was on cash money was that who
kind of introduced you into the cash
Converse 17 Mac 10 did I think Mac 10 we
don't give him enough flowers man you
know I agree I agree with Mac 10 I feel
like he's not as active we don't see him
on like interviews like we see a lot of
these other things right you see his
last interview he was like yeah he
wouldn't answer no questions he was like
yeah was that what they said
well they said y'all shot up 37 people
that's what they said hmm I was like he
knows what's up you know what to do but
but uh so your time on cash money was
solid like what was amazing
so far in your rap career right
because you've done records with
everybody
um what has been one time where you can
remember as like your fondest memory as
a fan of this [ __ ]
while being in it while being in it were
you almost were like damn look who I'm
standing next to or damn look who I'm on
the stage with or damn look what I'm on
this record with like what was that
moment for you just recently with
Raphael Saadiq wow I know that's crazy
right through
so Scarface probably is my favorite
rapper so I take that back right
um
I'm not taking it back it's three
moments I can't do one because now it's
been so long it's been 15 years so it's
three specific times
the first time is when Jay-Z I was in
Jay-Z's office at devjammy he's like
talking about how dope I was and he
wanted to sign me he was like yo you
wanted the best I ever heard do it from
the West
that [ __ ]
I couldn't even talk during the whole
meeting like my [ __ ] d one of my best
friends had to talk for me
because I had listened I had consumed
that much hope I mean to where I'm
living my life slanging drugs to this
[ __ ] music and one day I'm sitting in
his office and he telling me how great I
am
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up that's tough
like I mean I was like tough not signing
to him was tough I'm saying
um
that was one of them
the second one of them
probably
[Music]
okay so then that's where the Raphael
Saadiq comes in I just did a record with
him probably with the within a year ago
and you know I was talking to him Richie
Rich hooked me up with him and he gave
my number and we was talking chopping up
he's like yeah I know you is I [ __ ] with
your [ __ ] you tough
and and I sent him a record and just how
helpful he was he was explaining certain
things that [ __ ] was like crazy this
Raphael she threes it's my mom you know
it's kind of like one of my mom's
favorite bands right Tony Tone I grew up
to this [ __ ] and this is where I feel
Sadiq like still Ray is my [ __ ] for r b
for me so that [ __ ] was like crazy even
now I sometimes be like I got his number
in my phone I'd be like damn
Raphael Saadiq
and um
the third one is not really me
right the third one is
and I don't think people really know but
it's when Jay Rock
win went gold
um
right why was that such a big deal
because I know where we came from I know
how much [ __ ] we went through
and J-Rock for people who don't know
like there was an entire generation of
La hip-hop that was kind of shunned
exactly and and he was a part of it you
were a part of it and so many others
were part of it
and because forever the only only dude
who really had the the any attention or
love was game yeah we at Dr Dre
production
honestly it matters the producer is the
key yeah I'm saying but
Jay Rock win
when I seen when they had put out a
press release that they went gold so the
first record that he you know he had the
record that was the with future and
Kendrick right now on the soundtrack
Platinum right right but then the
win-win happened and I seen a press
release go out
like it was like a part of me that just
felt like weight came off you know like
my shoulders and it had [ __ ] to do with
me right I mean it was just
like damn man like look what we had to
go through to get here like it's it [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] me up now how many years
later you know I mean like and like my
[ __ ] went through a lot man we don't
even talk as much as we used to you know
we don't see each other as much as we
used to but like that [ __ ] meant so much
to me like that [ __ ] was so important I
had to see that happen you know I I
think about peeing certain homies all
the time problem right Bishop you know
all the [ __ ] just to try to bring the
West Coast together and to be shunned
[ __ ] Nipsey yeah nip man like that [ __ ]
I it bothers me that I can't see him get
his [ __ ] you know everybody finally
showing him love and it's like y'all
waited till this man was gone now I
remember having interviews with Nipsey
where around the time where he was
really not [ __ ] with the fact that
Dre was not co-signing all these young
we all went through that yeah I mean and
we knew how important we just didn't
know why but we figured out why it was
so important but honestly man that
J-Rock getting that gold plaque for win
like that for sure is the most thirst
and I celebrated it to myself
I mean I wrote a song a verse about it
on somebody else feature and talked
about how hard it was for all of us and
how it finally happened for him you know
I'm saying that [ __ ] is like one of the
greatest things it's like one of the
greatest stories of hip-hop that's not
told how much [ __ ] he went through if
y'all know how much [ __ ] he went through
man and how cold it was for us and how
[ __ ] shut us down and shut us out and
people don't realize like that label was
started on j-rock's back exactly you
know what I'm saying people don't
understand the
the the different like there was the he
was on Warner Brothers and then that
they don't know how to handle nobody on
the west coast you know what I'm saying
so that didn't work out and then they
tried a strange music thing put them on
tour with tech you know I mean like
there's so much and when it all came
down it was right there it was all
sitting right there and so just to watch
that happen was like
man it was special even every time I hit
a commercial like I just smile
that's the song that's gonna live
forever yeah sinks and movies and hear
it in scenes at Sports Center I just
smiled so big and then nobody know what
I'm thinking but I'm like man thank God
yeah feel me thank God what was your
most successful record
certified was it what was your biggest
record as far as like so certified is
somewhere close to gold
I would say that good I think that good
is my greatest record it may not be the
most that has sold right but it's the
one produced by DJ head exactly first
beat and
um but it was the one we built from the
ground up and to me it was the first
time one of my records was celebrated
because it was a great Club record yeah
no not to a kind of certified obviously
those are fat that's a fantastic tomb
like you know what song I really loved
was the one with the um
what was the name of that that group
that was on the hook oh I get money or I
get dough I get dope that was so dope
the cataracts
um
but the most important obviously is
Tupac must die like that's the one
that's when I finally put my own brick
in hip-hop and it had my name on it for
that like the whole culture they
couldn't unify behind me for no moment
when it comes to music I mean and that
became that moment where it's like bam
I'm there I'm saying so now I feel like
I'm you know really that's why I got
still I got [ __ ] to do still I got [ __ ]
that make crack it's on now I know
you're sitting on I mean you haven't put
out
a ton of music recently I'm just
starting putting out singles again yeah
I'm just starting I just mean in terms
of like your output hasn't been crazy
but the song's a matter yeah but it's
gonna go up now
um me and you feel the same way about
one album and that is doggy style so I
think doggy style is in my life the most
important album ever it's definitely the
greatest hip-hop of all time I put it
around two or three you know the number
one clearly but um
doggy style like changed my life that
was what's funny is I wasn't even a fan
of doggy style like that that's
literally probably 12 years old or 13
years old bro I was five
and my grandma got that tape on accident
in the mail remember used to be able to
go in the magazine remember that so she
had like 15 tapes delivered to her house
and one of them was doggy style I don't
know how I got in there but my grandma
was old as [ __ ] she didn't [ __ ] Snoop
Dogg that's how I [ __ ] got it it's a
[ __ ] cartoon cover she don't know
what the [ __ ] Snoop Dogg so she gave
everybody so she gives me doggy style
and I'd already had like Boyz II Men
some Boys to Men [ __ ] right but doggy
style I'm five I'm in kindergarten and
I'm at at night in my bed with my little
Walkman this is horrible parenting yes
you know what this was funny that's why
you go because I had already learned the
entire [ __ ] album by heart and then
my mom had heard me listening to it and
freaked out and took it took the tape
from me I already knew it and then I and
then I found it and took it back
and yeah what's funny is I have no
personal connection to God I just love
that album is so important I remember
the first time I ever met snooker I'm
like bro you changed my life without you
don't understand like you you Loki
turned me out as a five year old I have
no personal connection to dog's Dad it's
just such a per I think it's a perfect
album and I think Snoop Dogg is like
I you know I feel like somehow he's
still underappreciated please the
greatest hip-hop artist ever he's the
greatest hip-hop artist ever with the
greatest hip-hop album ever and again
it's tough It's in your face you know I
mean Snoop is like I was just telling my
partner and I say this a lot of snoopers
like McDonald's man he came out you send
me Big Mac yo that he had the gangster
rap like this fast food like it's the
Big Mac it's gangsta rap and since then
he's been able to deliver pimping and
chicken nuggets you know what I'm saying
he's been able to deliver gospel albums
and parfaits all kind of Reggae [ __ ] and
all kind of [ __ ] and everything in the
world I think he's the I think I think
he's the biggest I I you know I think
Snoop I think when you say he's the
greatest that's why I say greatest I
understand that because he's the biggest
he's like he said he's like McDonald's
because nobody doesn't know who Snoop is
I don't care how old you are exactly my
90 year old lady knows who Snoop Dogg is
exactly nobody has ever been in here you
know him because he's a [ __ ] rapper
yep they don't know him because he does
this that that oh the rapper Snoop is
Snoop man and I've been hearing a lot of
slack about that like people like I
don't have no person people are crazy
because I don't have no personal
connection to doggy style that's not
like I heard you know who am I in the
songs like okay cool but when I was
coming to my own feel me I'm more of a
baby dog food you know what I mean or
the shadiest one I'm a baby of those
products I know you love the shadiest
yeah like with a whole nother regards
but doggy style is what hip-hop is all
about like when cool hurricane them
through that party on August 11th I
think it's 1973. you know I mean and it
was a party
that's Snoop Dogg's music you came to
the most cultural phenomenon of a party
ever with that project
yeah I think Snoop has
not only that album but I just think in
terms of like figuring out like everyone
who does music their goal should be to
figure out
what's new figured out and that's how to
no matter what's going on like Snoop
don't need a record on the radio to be
relevant Snoop is never not going to be
relevant never and how do you do think
about it I was at home on peacock
watching this [ __ ]
literally throwing on I'm not watching
the Olympics I've been watching this
we'll talk about the Olympics was
throwing a javelin cuz and that bro they
got
he got an Olympic NBC jacket on talking
about how the horse was [ __ ] walked and
his cousin that's what I'm saying he's
cussing no he's he's yes no he's talking
about the whole man that horse is [ __ ]
walking I see him on Channel 11 cousin
Christina Devine look Christina cuz I
was like
God damn that's really what greatness
looked like this motherfucker's crazy
but
again man when you really step back and
you look at that like I said you go back
to August 11 1973 it's a party it's Dr
Dre DJing and Snoop on I think the only
artist I've seen that might have a
chance to be that big like in 30 years
is maybe Drake but I don't think Drake
has the personality and the chemistry of
this new best
Drake doesn't represent culture that's
the problem I mean like Snoop is the
phenomenon because he's the centerpiece
in the face of probably black America's
greatest
uh maybe not as celebrated but most
famous culture gang culture man
he is the face of it right Crips and and
he was defeated well he was the face of
it during a time when the Allure was at
an all-time high well think about it
right you you we talked about this the
other day colors is the initial exposure
at the highest level right you move
forward you get boys in the hood which
is a film about it that does 70 million
right 91 and then here go these [ __ ]
you know Dr Dre and Snook it's like a
they picked up boys in the hood and just
like let's finish it off and Snoop just
took it to a level you know you iced tea
gangster rapping then Snoop just
finished and he's the face Drake
situation is different because he's just
a pop star Drake has always been a pop
star it's like Snoop didn't start as a
pop star no and even now as much as
possible it's still not a pop star he's
still not a problem he's still Snoop
Dogg he still Snoop like he ascends past
some of these things like you said some
[ __ ] don't make sense and Snoop
I I like if you were to say like Snoop
would be if we think you know 30 years
down the line that Snoop would be
hosting shows of Martha Stewart or
hosting the Olympics you were just in
1994 if someone would have told you that
you would have said what if you would
have told me he was going to be out of
prison right I thought he was going to
go to [ __ ] prison for murder so again
man Snoop is just
a different anomaly man everything
you know
should you know should doesn't get
enough credit Dr Dre doesn't get enough
credit you know you still got probably
the greatest Vision with Suge Knight who
understood the vision for what was going
on right you got the greatest people the
greatest person probably at the time or
period making hip-hop records I mean and
they put together
August 11 1973 the greatest party the
West Coast ever had
this is the greatest party we ever
offered the world like you came to this
party and Snoop is on the mic and Warren
G is on the couch it's the greatest
party you've ever been to you hear it
you they got the liquor they got a
special liquor that they drink you drink
Gin and Juice you got the lingo it's the
culture is there yeah for me it's the
greatest party you could go to and no
matter what we think about hip-hop it's
still rooted in a party well it's funny
because you and I have had an argument
about you said Drake's not hip hop no no
no and I said listen Drake makes hip-hop
music and you said well Drake there's no
culture with Drake I think Drake makes
rap records
okay and I and I understand the concept
of and and the reason I really kind of
didn't even care about this conversation
no more is because I never thought of it
as a derogatory thing
like I never thought it was a derogatory
thing to to classify things I don't
again I'm back to the same point of I
don't care how you want me to look at
you let's talk about the classification
of things so we have some sense of
things that we can share versus we
create in a world where everybody could
be anything they want I don't like that
right like you know I mean I don't think
that's wise I think that's really
ignorant and it's going to come into a
place it's going to breed a lot of
people wasting their time there's gonna
be a lot of people that's convenience
already confused we already come into
this world confused and you're allowing
me to exist in a space of confusion
right which means the suicide rate is
gonna go up but
um
with Drake specifically hip-hop is
culture this lingo is Styles Cuisine
It's Fashion everything about it is the
flavor feel me the flavor it's like you
know what I mean it's like soul food
it's like
like yes like the concept of fried
chicken initially could be Soulful right
that don't mean Kentucky Fried Chicken
sell soul food
they got greens that don't mean they
sell soul food they got all the stuff
that don't mean they sell soul food
right okay it was popularized by hip-hop
but it is not exclusive Debbie Harry was
rapping in the [ __ ] serious entry
saying Drake makes rap music not but
he's not hip-hop no I I think that he's
not a cultured rapper he has no culture
he doesn't represent any culture Drake
is a fantastic rapper who makes
fantastic rap songs that turn into pop
songs and he could sing his [ __ ] ass
off the way he sings he he can uh carry
a note only the way he can he makes
fantastic records non-stop is one of my
favorite [ __ ] records period for me
but again to compare him to somebody
that's carrying the burden of culture on
their back like a Jay-Z or Snoop these
dudes represent entire Realms of Worlds
of [ __ ]
I mean ideals all of this they represent
it with the way they talk the way they
speak everything about what they're
doing they're they're walking with more
Drake is a I mean and I don't want to
simplify his life because I'm sure he
had his own struggles but this is a kid
that come from Nickelodeon that's a
rapper what you know I mean it's just a
different plight this [ __ ] came from a
dope spot this [ __ ] came from feel me
Long Beach cripping the pipes are
different it's like calling you know
man it's just crazy but again I never
thought the KFC analogies I mean it
makes sense yeah I never thought of it
as a negative connotation I didn't think
could Drake be considered um one of the
greatest of all time then in your eyes
artists rapper MC
yeah as a rap show hell yeah that
[ __ ] rap I'ma [ __ ] a rap but
again
hip-hop is his own special thing right
right right so like he could be one of
the greatest rappers he could wrap his
ass off I'm gonna [ __ ] her up he could
rap yeah I mean but then again people
talk about writing and all kind of [ __ ]
but yeah I mean listen I think that um
that's a discussion that's been beat
over the head I think Drake
I'm confident Drake and rap it's not
it's obvious because correct yeah I mean
now now [ __ ] Stevie Wonder what I
have liked him to have replied to Pusha
T sure yeah eat it that's different he
didn't want that smoke you don't go to
the culture she's different when you go
into the root of culture but he but he
did give me he got Meek Mill up out of
here for a couple years yeah but Meek is
and as as much as Mika's that's
different Meek is somebody who literally
his whole story is I was broke now I'm
rich that's fair yeah I mean push is
different
push I told everybody I said that that
ain't Meek Mill y'all better different
and all these white kids who don't know
about the clips and push your teeth
y'all don't know what you're signing up
for and he knew if he gave a record he
would give life to that record you don't
want people to hear that record so the
best way to do it is just back away like
oh that you know that way you don't
because if you mention him
people going to hear that and when they
hear that
you know violence is violence and they
gonna know like that [ __ ] is savagery
because that [ __ ] but pushes the
product of culture that's savagery yeah
one of my favorite rappers ever so it
pushes [ __ ] man that [ __ ] is [ __ ] I
was just I was like chomping at the
[ __ ]
and I'm one of those guys that was
cheering for Drake in the Meek Mill
battle and you know me too me too at the
time I just wanted him to fight back
like don't let these dudes pick on you
you know stand up like you know get
cracked yeah I didn't appreciate like
Meek's whole entire
Twitter [ __ ] and I just thought he
wasn't I didn't I just thought he
stepped out of character a lot and I you
know I didn't find out is his character
right
but look come to find out he was just
being himself
at first he was something changed
exactly it's so good so with Drake came
with [ __ ] back to back I remember
like oh but it but you know what it
might have [ __ ] Drake up because he
turned into a super tough guy after that
and then but but then pushing T was like
hold up it's different yeah
push is one of those guys where you're
like
you know the same thing with and
Kendrick's not a gangster rapper but you
know nobody wants it with Kendrick
that's the product of culture nobody
like like you notice like I'm like yo
nobody wants smoke or Pusha T nobody
wants smoke with Kendrick Lamar and
nobody really wants smoke with Freddie
Gibbs either because Fred has had some I
dare people to say his name on records
there's like certain artists where
you're like yo Royce the five nine you
don't want that problem you don't want
the Royce to five nine problem on a
record Lupe was only until I was teasing
yeah but they're friends they got a
podcast together but what's funny is
look so
you don't want problems with the root of
culture yeah like when you see somebody
represents a bunch of people
like they represent a lifestyle they
represent the hopes and dreams you don't
want to [ __ ] with that person and some
of these dudes really represent that and
not being one I mean some guys that
represent a lot yeah you'll just notice
certain people like just you don't say
their name
you know you know I will say this one of
those guys who I thought would just be a
bad idea to step two was Eminem but I
thought MGK got him
and I don't think he got him lyrically
but I think he won the battle I don't
even think Eminem has really good my
favorite Eminem diss record is the one
with you MGK
my favorite [ __ ] was the uh the [ __ ]
hits the fan like all that [ __ ] like all
that [ __ ] I love that era when there was
just a lot of mixtape [ __ ] of him
talking I talk about Ja Rule
about that [ __ ]
the only good disc records on Java's
fifth oh yeah everything else I could do
just the Eminem like but the Eminem
record
well he did MGK that was one of my
favorite because you know why he had fun
with it I just think that MGK won
because it was too close
and MGK had a great record MGK had a
great record and the fact that we even
thought about it means mgk1 well because
Eminem is by the way MGK is not a like
he's a good rapper you know what I'm
saying he's a rock star not even in it
but he's not in the same Arena or world
but the difference is a great song
versus a great rap feel me also the
subject matter was like yeah yeah that's
made a great record same thing think
about think about so when Pusher put out
his freestyle against Drake Pusher
wasn't even trying to rap He was just he
went to hit him up around with that
first freestyle that's why I couldn't
wait to see the second record because
I'm like oh this is just him just
being extremely disrespectful at hitting
record he hasn't even implied himself as
an MC yet yeah yeah no it's definitely
again the root of culture I like the
Eminem just to MGK like I thought that
this itself I was my favorite dish I
thought he had a lot of fun I think he
emceed his ass off but again competing
with a a record is different and the MGK
that's probably MGK's best record too
it's not I mean I love MGK uh he's been
putting out some rock [ __ ] lately that
reminds me of like Blink-182 and [ __ ] so
I'm like hey this is this reminds me of
high school look it was bad he shot was
cool he had some cool joints but that
one is probably his greatest record
that's the thing yeah I mean I feel the
same way about Nas I think Ethan is not
his greatest record I hate that beat you
hate to be yeah that beat is [ __ ]
fire Ron browse what's your favorite
diss track ever
um the [ __ ] in You by Common
favorite or greatest my favorite
favorite not greatest favorite
I think the greatest is hit them up
that's probably the greatest you know
Vaseline is crazy that's a toughness up
there man uh my favorite dish record
damn
honestly the greatest is probably back
to back though because that still gets
played on the radio and in the club
yeah it's different too that's a monster
um
somebody just like a record for
playability
favorite dish record damn that's so good
this you know what I won't lie and uh
there's probably gonna give me some [ __ ]
but dollars and since DJ quit oh man he
said eah t but should I continue left
out the G because the g ain't in you
that record was fire
higher I asked eight about that I said
when you heard that line did you at
least like
because that line was crazy what'd he
say we said Eiht but should I continue
you left out the G because the g ain't
in you what did a say oh no he was like
yeah no that [ __ ] was hard that's a good
record
that that one was like and I liked a I
like H still but it was like [ __ ] nah
that [ __ ] was crazy we didn't have to be
that dollars and sense dollars and cents
is legendary that's a quick another guy
second is takeover
and people don't talk about taking I
don't know why I don't think it's
because it's not a full disc record
there's lines on it we got it a lot of
people on takeover no masonically I
think it's probably my favorite uh I
think it's such a the beat is so good
ether was great because I'm a Nas fan
before I'm a j fan Ethan was like the
tighter way bro
hit him up my boy D it was like [ __ ]
Jay-Z it was just like that [ __ ] was
dick sucking lips yeah you can't beat
that type of energy
um I was teasing my boy my boys are
super duper nice fan and I'm a super at
that time hoe I [ __ ] with hoe when
takeover came out on the blueprint I was
just playing it over he was in the car
like yeah your boy don't want none of
this smoke and either drop I was like
[ __ ] Christ
[ __ ] man that ether man
that [ __ ] is a part of the culture that
record is a part of the culture that
title that that music is part of me now
you can it's it's a verb yeah people say
man you got ether like Stan yeah Lance
exactly everyone says no you're a stand
for that [ __ ] stand off of some
hip-hop [ __ ] yeah yeah NASA you know
what song I don't think it enough love
was um the song The Blueprint two on the
blueprint too or that just blazeby where
he's like uh when the when the when the
the what did he say
when the grass is cut the snakes will
show gotta thank the little homie Nas
for that though
just because he wears a koofie it don't
mean that he right is it Uchi Wally
Wally there is a One mic it's a black
girl lost as a shorty owe you for ice no
one talked about that because the battle
was already won by Nas it was over
what's funny is so
like write my favorite Naz verse like
all my homies obviously if you like
Jason that's my favorite rapper ever MC
ever that's crazy it's Nas that's dope
but so but if you're a Jay-Z fan
naturally
Nas fans literally they Clash I love
both but I was I was on that side where
I was like man [ __ ] Jason so as a whole
fan right as a deep way and nice fans I
remember right I would you know we would
be talking [ __ ] to this day as much as
even I've grown to appreciate I've
always liked Nas no as a rapper I just I
thought your magic was overrated I
thought crazy listen now it's just a
it's just to shave this one for New York
greatest rap it's just the greatest rap
album I'm not even mad if that's what
you feel right but I'm just saying it
was it was super you know a regional
idea that became bigger but over the
time right my favorite nausea We Major
the verse on Kanye record right
um even now right listening to him now
will hit like put on hit and do [ __ ] for
hit right it's amazing but I find myself
still teasing my homies like I'm like
yeah Lil Nas X got Nine's name
funny right how that [ __ ] never dies
you still be teasing your homies like
yeah this is the new Nas you know [ __ ]
be high
[Music]
shout out to Nas the empty now this is
my favorite man
now this is my favorite MC and Connie is
my favorite artist
kind of is just unbelievable completely
just discography I don't know I [ __ ] the
music everything he does an animal he's
an animal man [ __ ] he is an animal I
think um
I was just not a fan of the Jesus king
album outside of that
but I'm also I mean we discussed I'm an
atheist I'm not into the god [ __ ] you
hate anything they got spiritual I don't
hate anything I just I just was like man
this is just forcing it down I guess
it's kind of like the the you know for
me it was like you like Jesus Walks yeah
but it was one song so you said an album
wasn't in jail no I wasn't there were
some beats on there that were crazy
shout out to the homie bugs but the
whole album sure wasn't it was Jesus
Walks that's what I say it wasn't Jesus
don't do that no no no no Jesus Walks of
Jesus I'm talking to my subject
matter-wise but Jesus Walks still is
agreement I mean it's one of the best
kindness Satan is probably playing Jesus
walk right
Jesus Walks is a [ __ ] Banger right
and it was one song on a song of I mean
1921 records whatever College Dropout
was it was like one out of that much
Jesus Walks was or Jesus king was like
super unfocused now uh Kanye he was not
focused and it was like I thought that
the all the [ __ ] the [ __ ] he was
doing with all the um the choir and all
that [ __ ] was
corny
I like that I don't think it was
quantity
has always been a spiritual person no I
don't disagree I just thought that [ __ ]
was very um like purp it didn't feel
genuine
yeah you know what I'm saying like it
just sounds like I think he was a I
think he was in a weird place and I
think he was going through it for sure I
mean personally he's been going through
a lot mentally I mean I think I think he
had to kind of get spiritually centered
and I think I forgive Kanye for all
kinds of [ __ ] and I forgive him for
the for the Jesus I mean Connie is my
favorite artist ever like I love Kanye I
can't wait for donda to come out I just
hope it does not disappoint
I don't think it will how could it live
up to these expectations I think it's
gonna I mean for me I think it will
I just need a I just need to compensate
Kanye album and I'll be happy I'll be
honest with you
Kanye could do everything right now and
I really Connie is probably the only
rapper ever who just do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants I just like you bro
whatever you ain't gonna do cause I'm
[ __ ] with it and and I and I think
it's always from a genuine place
um
has Kanye been corny I don't really
think Kanye I don't think he does things
without Soul no I don't think Kanye's
going yeah yeah no I just said I just
said for me I just thought that the sure
sure I remember choir thing just it just
speak to me it's just one thing I have
to go to a Kanye concert I've never been
to a concert I've been to every tour
except the Pablo tour because the date I
was supposed to go to I might get him to
come perform at my birthday party I've
been to all the Kanye tours the best
show I ever been to was was the Yeezus
tour he had a mountain on stage I heard
about the have Kanye perform at my
birthday party that's what I might do I
might where's this gonna be at I don't
know to be at like a house a small house
he could Rock like 30 people go old
school
for me that would be like crazy let's
get to it hey I'll be there just give me
my invite man all right all right well
look man G Malone um plug the podcast No
Ceilings
um
black effect Network c network why don't
you do video
because I was I wasn't comfortable with
where I was at speaking now we're just
gonna get into it okay because I feel
like it'd be much bigger with this video
I had to get good at it versus Russian
like I think a lot of rappers rush into
it and then that's why they struggle so
I just wanted to get good at it first so
you feel comfortable now because I feel
like the visual aspect of podcasts is
important yeah and it's going to take it
to that level man yeah No Ceilings it's
available everywhere you listen to
podcasts it's all about you know
conversations with pariahs in our
community and polarizing topics and
really running into the fire instead of
leaving everybody in the house burning
we're just trying to run into the fire
to rescue as many people as we can
instead of just walking by taking a
picture of a burning house
that's what no selling is so go get that
and then there's uh music every week
every week you're putting out a song
every week no no I'm saying new I wish
no I'm dropping music I'm saying every
week it's I'm speeding up to every week
right now I've dropped three songs I've
dropped record with snooping iced tea
snooping iced tea and Ty right and then
I dropped a song with game and corrupt
and now the next song is with 40 in
exhibit oh oh so you're really just
legendary features only here man for
years we wanted to to be a part of the
West Coast and we felt like they wasn't
so now that the the opportunity is
present I'm finally getting what was the
iced tea call like that was in person oh
that was amazing there's ice T's on
another he's in another Snoop r as
advertised iced tea is uh
I mean a legend on TV now iced tea and
Snoop was ours advertising those are not
characters
there's no other body else up there some
a lot of rappers 99 of the rappers shout
out to Ice T's turned into a a great
Arizona citizen now yeah it is out in I
think it was in Chandler iced tea is
we're claiming him now yeah as you
should ice tea is as advertised he's
exactly what it is correct what you
think corrupt too man there corrupt yeah
corrupt up here Snoop like Snoop that
iced tea is that those two guys are as
advertising is besides dubs he's the
shadiest one yeah because I think you
would it's my favorite would you say
it's the most slept on hip-hop album on
from the West Coast ever why yeah yeah
yeah that's fair oh no I wouldn't say
it's the most slept on I would probably
leave that for Street Gospel I was gonna
say streets is a mother
and or 40 days 40 nights
four days for the nights are super nasty
but streets I think how much the West
reveres
Street Gospel that's why like streets as
a mother is is is pretty remarkably
close but corrupt was already a
successful artist yeah so but Street
Gospel sugar-free like I don't think the
world knows yeah I don't think I also
don't think like like people understand
how much influent sugar free had yeah
yeah just on everywhere yeah not just
not just here but I'm saying so I think
that album will be the most underrated
and he's he comes as Advertiser yeah
that's for sure yeah I saw him walking a
[ __ ] on a leash in Vegas that's the
real deal um but the thing about the
shadiest one is what Illmatic is to New
York okay it's very much he's my my
probably
when West Side connection was like like
when bow down came out WC was my
favorite uh I just thought dub seek it
out rap anybody from La at the time I
was [ __ ] nasty bro and just his
little aneurysm skip connected all of
that
when I hear Illmatic that's what I hear
the shadiest one I hear this super deep
dive into true culture like Queen's
Bridge culture and Dempsey was doing
[ __ ] with like Gang Starr he was on the
um but before that I'm talking about the
Shady no no that was way before that
yeah but I'm talking about the shadiest
one where he dives into La culture
probably greater than anybody ever had
sonically and and also like lyrically
like the lingo he was using what he
talked about he talked about the the
part the house party he talked about all
of the lifestyles and situations it was
like
um that's our Illmatic
you know I mean and I and I'm sad that
other people you know huh you I mean I
mean I've never heard that besides from
you yeah yeah it's aromatic okay the
what we just don't have as much sway
over in the media you know as obviously
the creators of the actual [ __ ] genre
as they should but that's our Illmatic
okay say this one is aromatic all right
last question 2001 or The Chronic 2001.
me too yeah I mean I was [ __ ] I
barely [ __ ] knew what doggy style was
but I have to go back and consume doggy
style in The Chronic I heard them right
and I think 2001 was way better revalue
re-replay value now but personally for
me it's 2001 but when you just talk
about sheer greatness The Chronic is the
father nah for sure the chronic birth to
everybody [ __ ] but I just think like if
I'm listen if yeah I'm playing 2001 2000
yeah all right yo G Malone go check out
the No Ceilings podcast everywhere
hopefully be on YouTube soon yeah Google
me Google new music everywhere just go
to my Spotify page and go support and
you know shout out to our 7-Eleven this
uh this I haven't seen a big Gold Cup
this big since I was about nine hundred
ounces of water cold oh [ __ ]